there is a place beneath those ancient  runes in the mover that calls out to the  boldest among them we are the flame they  cry and darkness is us they descend  spurred on by a disease of riches and  redemption to may bear whatever  blasphemous abnormality may slumber  restlessly and on how they abyss  but darkness is insidious Sara and  madness can't bind cracks in the  sturdiest of honest the most resident  minds  and below in that limitless castle of  chaos  they will realize the truth habit  we are not the flame they will cry off  we are what moths and we are doomed  and their screams will  the business cycle pian stones of the  darkest dungeon